Let's pray together over day 13.
Father, I rejoice. I rejoice in
the fact that you provide that which you require.
There has never been a time when you have not
opened the door
for us to meet the requirements that you have for
us. You require holiness, and rightly so.
But it says that Jesus, in Hebrews 13, says Jesus
suffered outside the city gate to make the people holy
through his own blood. Lord, you are the lamb,
just like Abraham centuries before was promised
that you would provide yourself a lamb.
You did provide, and I praise you that you have bridged the
gap that is between us and you. I praise you for providing
holiness. You provided judicial holiness for us.
You declared us not guilty, but you also provided a brand new
life, a life that is ours in Jesus. You
gave yourself up for us
to make us holy, having cleansed us, and I thank you, Lord,
that that holiness is available and continuing, and we
rejoice in it. We thank you for providing it, that
purity that you require. You have also provided the
faithfulness that you require. You have made for us, and I thank you for it.
Lord, would you help our hearts, my heart,
would you help our hearts to be glad and
thankful and rejoicing in the provision that you have made for
us of holiness?
Lord, I pray that you would now bring about everything that
you've provided.
Don't just do it in the saving and the
forgiving of past sins, but Lord, also do it in the
creating of holiness in my own heart,
in the unseen world of the heart. Lord, would
you do something deeper than just forgiving sin?
Would you also break its power? Would you recreate my soul
anew in the image of Jesus? I pray in his name.
Let's continue to pray and seek the Lord together.